rubble and debris the remnants of Holmes
old and damaged materials piled up along
the few roads around the Tiny Village of
novuska but in the center of the
community there's something new
containers linked together creating a
modular housing community shelter for
vulnerable residents
everything is fine the main thing is
that we help each other olha makarenko
and Gregory moved in in the fall with
the help of our interpreter Petro they
explained winter was tough the units
were cold and they often had to cook on
a little gas-powered Hot Plate the
electrical infrastructure was regularly
knocked offline by airstrikes on the day
we visited the power was on the fritz
possibly because of the heavy rain
we're alive and thank God their survival
is something to Marvel at the village is
close to the Russian Bella Russian and
border at the start of the full invasion
Nova salivka was nearly leveled when
Russian forces began launching aerial
attacks and streaming into Ukraine
Russians occupied large swaths of the
region and encircled the nearby city of
chernihif after many battles the area
was liberated in April 2022 when Global
News first visited the community in May
of that year a group of residents rushed
over thinking we were a charity bringing
food
a bread truck now makes regular visits
to ensure people get nourishment but
their souls are tortured I can't get it
out of my head the noises of flying
Rockets or airplanes is all in my head
it flies and falls and we see someone's
house on fire in spite of everything
their Hospitality overflows the couple
showed us around their new community
their unit is Tiny two sets of bunk beds
some shelves a little table and two
windows but it's what's on their phones
that they desperately wanted to share oh
beautiful their garden and daughter
their pride and joy
Nadia who we also met in 2022 took us
into her unit she loves to read and is
happy to have a few books everything
here has been given to her yeah
it's better than nothing she says in the
summer I lived in a barn she's
originally from Siberia but she's called
Ukraine home for the past 50 years tears
streak her face as she talks about what
she terms the Russian policy and the
suffering it's causing Ukraine
this is what's left of nidio's home she
wasn't here when it was hit by a rocket
she's nearby and every once in a while
stops in to cut some fresh flowers
building a bouquet she chats and smiles
she can visit but it can't compare she's
homesick just across the road is where
olha and Greg hori once lived they also
return regularly to tend to their Garden
oh being so close to their old lives
bring Solace and sorrow they still don't
know when or if someone will help them
rebuild but they're grateful to have a
place to sleep and that they're able to
stay close to their neighbors
Crystal commands in Global News Nova
salivka Ukraine